Das Gesicht eines Menschen verrät
uns seine Gefühle,
eine universelle Sprache,
die jeder versteht.
Doch es gibt Menschen,
denen die Fähigkeit fehlt,
die Emotionen in der Mimik ihres
Gegenübers zu lesen.
Menschen mit Autismus wie Rainer
können in den Gesichtern ihrer
Mitmenschen nichts erkennen.
Dadurch haben sie Schwierigkeiten,
auf andere emotional zu reagieren.
Sie fühlen sich ausgegrenzt und einsam.
Wissenschaftler an der Humboldt-Universität
in Berlin erforschen,
wie man Menschen beibringen kann,
Gefühle richtig zu deuten.
Isabel Dziobek entwickelt mit
ihrem Team Methoden,
mit denen Autisten das, was eigentlich
intuitiv geschehen soll, erlernen können.
Mein persönliches Ziel ist tatsächlich,
Menschen mit Autismus,
ob’s jetzt Kinder sind oder
Erwachsene,
zu helfen, in der Welt besser
zurechtzukommen.
Ich glaube, das ist ‘n ganz
wesentlicher Aspekt,
mit anderen Menschen auszukommen.
Und das ist so wichtig, nicht nur
für unser Sozialleben,
auch für unser Berufsleben, für praktisch
alles in unserm Leben.
Ich glaub, dass ’n ganz wesentlicher
Aspekt ist,
dass wir andere Menschen lesen können.
Isabel Dziobeks Team hat
eine Software entwickelt,
die autistischen Menschen ermöglicht,
das Erkennen von Emotionen zu üben.
Dafür haben Schauspieler mehr als vierzig
Gefühle mimisch zum Ausdruck gebracht.
Wie sehen wir aus, wenn wir gerührt,
frustriert
oder einfach glücklich sind?
Diese kleinsten Veränderungen in der Mimik,
in Tausenden von Ausdrücken,
müssen Autisten mühsam erlernen.
Eine Aufgabe besteht darin,
die Ausdrücke von Augen und Mund
richtig zusammenzufügen.
Autisten sollen verstehen,
welche einzelnen kleinen Bewegungen
welchem Gefühlszustand entsprechen.
In früheren Studien, die wir gemacht haben,
haben wir herausgefunden,
dass Menschen mit Autismus weniger
auf die Augen schauen,
wenn Leute Gefühle ausdrücken.
Nun sind die Augen aber ganz
besonders wichtig,
wenn wir Gefühle lesen wollen, weil sie
häufig am ausdrucksstärksten sind.
Deshalb zeigen die Wissenschaftler den
Autisten, wohin sie schauen sollen.
Nur drei Stunden Training pro Woche
verbessern das Lesen von Gesichtern.
Isabel Dziobek hat herausgefunden,
dass sich diese Fähigkeit
in einer messbaren Aktivierung
des Gehirns widerspiegelt
und welche Region dafür entscheidend ist.
Das Gehirn zu stimulieren, geht am
besten im Kindesalter.
Das Programm von Simone Kirst soll
autistischen Kindern
die soziale Interaktion erleichtern.
Denn Autisten verfügen genau wie
jeder andere über Gefühle.
Sie können sie nur nicht passend
ausdrücken.
Lutz hat das sogenannte
Asperger-Syndrom,
eine spezielle Entwicklungsstörung
innerhalb des Autismus.
Lutz geht auf eine normale Schule,
ist überdurchschnittlich intelligent.
Doch der Kontakt mit anderen Kindern
fällt ihm schwer.
Im Unterricht macht er richtig gut mit, er
hat Spaß dran, da klappt das ganz toll.
Das Problem und die Schwierigkeiten
sind dann die Pausen.
Lutz weiß nicht, was er machen soll.
Das Resultat ist dann, dass er durch die
Klasse rennt,
dass er anfängt, zu stänkern, zu schubsen –
einfach, um auf sich aufmerksam zu
machen und zu sagen:
„Hey, ich will mit euch reden.“
Aber er kann‘s nicht.
Das neue Trainingsprogramm wird heute
zum ersten Mal getestet.
Wird Lutz auf Anhieb die Gefühle
der Schauspieler
deuten und benennen können?
Ich glaube mal: eher ängstlich.
Im Programm für Erwachsene geht es darum,
die verschiedenen Gefühlsausdrücke
beim Gegenüber zu erkennen.
Kinder sollen zudem lernen, adäquat
auf die Emotionen
ihrer Mitmenschen zu reagieren.
Lutz macht ein solches Training
schon seit Jahren
und hat in dieser Zeit erhebliche
Fortschritte gemacht.
Es war ja nicht einfach mit Lutz.
Und da bricht man dann auch
mal in Tränen aus.
Und da hat er gelacht, da hat er sich
gefreut, das fand er total aufregend.
Und heute ist es so, wenn ich jetzt
’n Tränchen habe,
dann kommt er und
bringt mir ’n Taschentuch.
Er freut sich immer noch ein bisschen,
aber er weiß, es ist was Trauriges, und er
weiß, wie er reagieren muss.
Damit sie die Gesichter erkennen
und andere Menschen emotional
einschätzen können,
müssen autistische Menschen aber
permanent üben.